csgo's final major is now over and we
honestly couldn't have asked for a more
perfect ending zaiwu the chosen one
finally got his crown and he did it in
front of a home crowd but now that it's
all over what does it mean for the
future of Counter-Strike
[Music]
so the Paris major bracket turned out to
be just as unpredictable as every round
before it and before we go any further
yes
I was wrong I'm a man of passion and
loyalty to my region and by God if
liquid had a chance at winning a goddamn
major it's now yeah that couldn't have
been further from reality one
[Music]
bullet to
I am in disbelief liquid were demolished
all the confidence that Naf and OC
seemingly had disappeared once they got
onto the stage all credit to Apex
honestly but this is a team that liquid
should beat every day of the week or so
at least I thought honestly I shouldn't
be surprised at this point they love to
lose these now what was surprising was
heroic's outcome heroic had been one of
the most consistent teams in CS go over
the last year or so and with a grand
finals appearance at Rio they were
pretty much a lock for another one
however their first matchup wasn't going
to be easy although in my eyes heroic
were still definitely the favorites it's
hard to ever count out faze's clutch
Factor but after trading Maps heroic
shutdown Mirage sending phase packing
God Carrigan with that MP9
it gets the
gets the quaking
and heroic locked in for the semi-finals
now you'd think the hard part would be
over for Heroic they had just beat the
number five team in the world and
although gamer Legion loves to prove
everyone wrong every once in a while we
were watching an Unleashed Acadian but
once again gamer Legion surprised the
world thanks in large part to an
outstanding performance
the bomb is still in the hands of sui oh
they're gonna run right
way down he mows them all right down
well doesn't even get really a chance
Eva Antoine he's going to spray him all
down Claude kills from emo and now yabby
and Katie are showing up Emma with the
spray down he's so good he is Immortal
it's just test his left and there's
nothing to do game Legion with a
Legendary Run to make the grand finals
of the final major in CS go even his
biggest haters would admit that seeing
kadian lift a major trophy would be
something special for Counter-Strike but
this time around it just wasn't in the
cards that being said with the numbers
he's still putting up I think we're
going to see a lot more kadian in the
years to come now back on the other side
of the bracket were the home favorites
Vitality heading into their first match
against into the breach Vitality hadn't
lost a single map in the tournament and
despite some brilliant individual
efforts from the side of ITB especially
from Cipher Vitality would hang on to
their perfect record but as I mentioned
Cipher was the real highlight of that
series the UK has been a pretty down bad
region over the years so to see a young
man come in with this much confidence
against one of the best players in the
world is a great thing to see Cipher is
definitely a player you're going to want
to keep on your radar going forward hell
even zyu himself had to give the Brit
some respect is that a start of
something between you and Cipher you
know especially early on when he was in
the headshots yeah I mean he me
so I decided to me a lot so
obviously he's a really good rifle and
Andrew most likely so yeah
if you keep like this he can be one of
the best ones made a name for himself on
a backstage yeah now it's time to get to
the real action after fighting off Apex
and capturing yet another 2-0 Victory
Vitality moved on to meet gamer Legion
in CS Go's Grand Finale it was time for
the party to get started the
Counter-Strike Gods truly blessed us we
got the outcome we were hoping to get in
Rio the home team playing in the finals
and let's just say Paris did not
disappoint we may have taken a break but
the crowd certainly has not
[Music]
the Golden Horn is ahead
and vitality is six rounds away
with the golden Hornets absolutely
buzzing it was the moment all of Cs had
been waiting 11 years for the last Grand
Final in CS go history and the stage was
set perfectly would we finally get to
see zybu get a win deserving of his
pedigree would Dupree further solidify
himself as the most decorated player in
the history of the game could Apex
finally prove all the doubters wrong or
would a group of perfect underdogs
deliver the most remarkable upset in the
history of the game well kudos to gamer
Legion for putting up one hell of a
fight I'm serious that team deserves the
community's utmost respect but God damn
no one was stopping zaibu from getting
this major
and another Clash assist into kill feeds
Spinks
Springs getting ever closer T side turn
instant execution kion's back and down
[Applause]
he falls away takes the spam and he
leans on who other than the legend of
lost whoever
the lead
but they turn back because they're so
afraid
they will take it integer on French soil
Isaac with everything on him
Vitality shot
[Applause]
with outstanding performances from the
entire Squad Vitality became the second
team ever to win a major without
dropping a single map and with an
unthinkable 1.54 rating zaiwu was of
course named tournament MVP just like
that
was all over
signs sincerely by millions
TV Paris major champions
team vitality
[Applause]
in the wake of the final CS go major
trophy lift we got it all unbridled
Elation a lot of tears and for whatever
reason a surprising amount of f-bombs
you had to do it with an international
team and now you've lifted it it's
poetic in Paris how does it feel
I don't know what to describe right now
it's so much joy you know I've been
criticized from day one being in game
leader but now I win a major so far
but admits all but amidst all the
celebration there was an elephant in the
room
what now well if you were hoping for
valve to finally drop some more news
about Counter-Strike 2 since you know it
would have been the perfect moment to do
it you'd be sadly let down as of
recording we still have no clue
what's going on with this game with that
said CS go is still technically not over
there's still a few tournaments left and
with no updates from valve we actually
have no idea when or how the transition
is going to be made what we do know is
that CS2 will be coming out sometime
this summer and before that happens
expect to see a lot of changes there are
of course plenty of teams who will just
play by ear CS2 will see massive changes
to the meta and it might be smart to
just see how certain players perform in
the first few months of that transition
period but for teams like Furia liquid
and Navi who had been underperforming
even before the major massive changes
are likely on the horizon I mean we have
already heard Rumblings from the navi
camp that blade and MPL are on their way
out personally I'm a lot more curious to
see which players are going to retire
we've already seen guys like fall and
comment on it but what other Pros are
going to use this as an opportunity to
hang up their mice I know a lot of older
players probably have some morbid
curiosity about Counter-Strike 2 but for
a lot of them taking the bound now would
probably be best with that said let me
pass it off to you guys what are your
feelings coming out of the last CS go
major ever and what do you hope to see
during this quote unquote transitional
period let me know in the comments and
as always stay safe and have fun
my favorite CS go highlight
moment
I I really liked uh Furia beating Navi
at home
last year I thought that was really
special even though they didn't make it
all the way
I thought it was really really really
really really really cool to see